derek chauvin the now former police
officer who pinned george floyd down
has been arrested he was charged with
third-degree murder a charge that's
applied when no intention to kill is
suspected
we're joined live now by kayla janae
johnson an activist from minneapolis
it's good to see you thanks for joining
us on rt um you took part in the
protests
tell us about that experience
um you know i was always the one to you
know take part
in protest but i never took full action
like i did on wednesday may 27th
i felt that i needed to be out there
it was important that i was out there to
stand for others who can no longer stand
anymore so i ended up getting to the
front line of protests
and we were peacefully protesting um it
was kind of scary because the police
were
throwing flash grenades off of the roof
of the precinct
they were you know shooting people with
rubber bullets people it was like a war
zone out there i ended up getting tear
gas
very badly i got hit with a flash
grenade in my
arm in the minneapolis the police
department ended up giving me a second
degree burn for peacefully protesting
that's the type of world we live in
right now it's scary
but i can no longer have fear anymore
because i feel as if they already you
know they already did
the wrong they they've done it to us
multiple times and we can just
we can't fear it anymore we have to
stand we have to that's the only thing
we have left
what message did you want to get across
by protesting
i don't regret what happened to me
and i feel like it made me stronger as a
person
and i want to i was there to make a
statement so that's why i don't regret
what happened to me i was there to make
a statement
and that's what i did
the officer who knelt on george floyd
has been charged with third degree
murder is that part of what you wanted
to achieve
i don't think he
i think he should have gotten higher
charge because
he murdered someone in broad daylight
it's on
people have it on multiple videos it was
it was straight murder there's no way
around it you can't justify it
it was murder the man was suffocated for
several minutes and that was murder
point blank it was murder
do you intend to continue protesting
i was out yesterday protesting
i will i have to work today so i can't
really go out right now
but yes i do continue if i can get out
there and know if i'm well and my
shoulder
is healed i will continue to protest and
stand
it seems like day after day the protests
are growing and they're even spreading
across the country and even
internationally
what needs to happen to make this come
to an end to get people off the streets
it's going to be hard to do that
honestly because
the peace has to come from within the
system
if the system doesn't change if the
people within the system who are
controlling the system
doesn't change there will be no peace
the
the saying is no justice no peace and
that
statement is literal if there's no
justice there will not
be no peace it's going to be hard to get
people off the streets
it really is we've seen them
sadly similar situations uh and and
similar protests in the past
how why why are these protests different
do you think this is going to be a
significant moment for the u.s do you
think it's going
to be a turning point
i i think the reason why
everything escalated the way it did
is because us as an african-american
community
we are tired of fighting the same fight
we've been fighting the same fight for a
hundred plus years
we've tried to protest peacefully we've
kneeled
everything we've tried everything and
people are at their wit's end about it
it's it's sad because it's like i don't
know
it's saying like i have a 10 year old
nephew he's an african-american
if he goes out one day we don't know if
he's gonna come home that day that's how
scary it is
that's how it's like as african
americans every day we step out of our
house we are risking our lives
we don't know what's coming next
minnesota's governor says the violence
that we've been seeing is no longer
about
george floyd's death is much bigger than
that do you think um
tell me what you think about what he
said and also do you think there's a
chance that these protests are going to
be
hijacked by opportunists
um it is more than george floyd's death
because as of right now we're fighting
for everyone who has
been brutalized by police officers
and the system and have not yet gotten
justice for it
um opportunists have already taken
charge
they just announced today on the news
that
a lot of these fires and initiate the
people initiating the lootings
are white supremacists i was just told
that
they're encouraging people to stay home
tonight because it's gonna be like
a war zone times 10. um i heard
people are getting assault rifles and
ready
i heard white supremacists start
blending in with the crowds
it's scary you don't know who is who out
there you know anything can happen
so opportunists have definitely already
taken charge
kela janae johnson an activist from
minneapolis thank you for
talking to us
you